[Music]
dj
kate will not be hitting the clubs this
weekend
on monday prince william and kate
middleton continued their current tour
of
scotland and the duke and duchess of
cambridge have been sharing highlights
of their trip to instagram
and during a visit to the scottish
violence reduction unit
we saw kate trying her hand at djing
followed by some mixed reviews from the
[Music]
audience
but always the duchess kate displayed
some royal etiquette
as she left her music dreams behind
thanks for leaving such a terrible song
in addition kate's wardrobe looked
familiar to fans of royal fashion
the blue dress was seemingly a nod to
this one
worn by princess diana in 1992
but william's fun was already well
underway during their trip
what can i get inside the flake in there
as well
on sunday he visited queens bay lodge a
nursing home in scotland
where the prince was called out for
flirting with some of the residents
and these cute moments shared to social
media might be part of a larger
initiative
as they follow the recent debut of
william and kate's new
youtube channel which royal expert katie
nichol told et
is part of their efforts to reach a
wider audience
we are seeing the royals work in a
different way
during this pandemic video has never
been
more important it makes them accessible
it's an
immediate way of communicating what
they're doing i think this is very
important for the cambridges to reach
out to a
a new demographic essentially a younger
audience they
realize the value of streaming they've
got a brilliant digital team behind them
we've seen more of them i think at home
relaxed
in their own time during the pandemic
through video conference calls and
videos that they've chosen to release
i think we'll see more of that the
youtube channel is
obviously an important medium for the
cambridges and
up until now they've shared that
platform with the royal family so i
think it's quite significant that we've
seen them
branch away set up their own channel and
given the emphasis that they are now
putting on
social media on videos this is really
important for them
we're covering the royal family in a
very different way today that's largely
down to the pandemic
we don't cover engagements the way we
used to we simply can't
have many of us on the ground covering
these engagements
so we're very dependent on the royals to
cover their engagement
and what they're up to through the
medium of video
[Music]